what do you think of the leak of the
Twitter files
I was
so
happy
that Elon gave the information to Matt
taibi and Barry Weiss who are both by
any metric lefties who are both
professional journalists of
long-standing with great resumes and
overnight now they're they're doing PR
for the world's Rich whatever the party
line was
the fact that you had all these
corporate journalists now having to play
catch up and not having control of the
microphone to me was just absolutely
amazing
um I think transparency is
what brought down in many aspects of
Soviet Union and what will bring down
what negative aspects of the regime we
have here
when you see the machinations behind the
scenes and then when you see the
rationalizations after the fact you
realize oh these people are not acting
in good faith the fact that for example
the New York Post article about the
hunter Biden laptop and how the New York
Times coveted as well they didn't
mention any kind of dick pics Twitter
made it so I couldn't even DM you the
link to the New York Post article which
was a tool they had previously used only
to prevent child pornography so that
shows to what extent they were willing
to put their thumb on the scale
but it also shows that
for any laymen when they're looking at
this to realize what you are perceiving
as news or information
is very much sculpted edited and guided
by powerful people who have a vested
interest in maintaining their uh Power I
think to me the important lesson is this
not a left to right thing oh not at all
powerless yes and but and also the
important lesson there I think at least
in the case of Twitter in our society
it's a it's a slippery slope you don't
get there overnight
you start you start using those tools a
little bit a little bit to slow down
this information to just a little bit
that you start uh sending emails to each
other a little bit and it becomes more
and more
um you you start forming justifications
you start getting a little more and more
comfortable kind of talking about the
stuff
um I think
there are several ways to fight that one
is having hardcore Integrity up front so
don't even open the door but I think
realistically human nature is what it is
and so I think the only way is through
transparency is this is why the nice I I
hate the fact they got politicized I
really hate that the right has have run
with it like look the left is planning
the rig elections and so on to me that's
it shouldn't be left or right it
shouldn't be about politics it's that
transparency is good other companies
should do the same Facebook should do
the same and in fact that transparency
will protect Facebook it will protect
Google look like this is our situation
tell us what to do really and we'll do
our best I remember when I was writing
the new right Twitter's line was we're
not going to tell you guys what the
metrics are by which we ban or censor
people because then Bad actors are going
to navigate around them and it's like
what are you doing like just tell people
in any establishment what are the rules
for which behavior is permissible if I
go to a store if I were return the
sweater is it cash back no refunds or if
I get store credit you know what I mean
so that they were having this place
which was presented as a
huge International Space for public
discourse and they're not telling you
ahead of time this is what we will
tolerate this is what we'll warn you
about this is what will kick you out
overnight that to me was crazy and
outrageous
um and I'm really pleased with to what
extent Elon is like it is being open
with their policies and what I'm really
want to commend him about
is uh now I'm triggered because one of
the things that he took over he's like
our first priority is getting rid of
child pornography and child exploitation
yeah yeah right that was he's like like
racial slurs homophobics there's
anti-semitic stories yeah yeah that's
cool kids kids getting harmed is number
one and you know he fired the old task
force because they weren't doing their
job uh Eliza blue who you know you know
she had been on this for a long time but
people who were victims of child
pornography child expectation were
emailing Twitter being like these are my
images get them off and they're like too
bad porn is allowed on Twitter he starts
trying to crack down on it this is a
very hard problem because these uh Bad
actors have mechanisms to evade uh you
know being banned they want to get there
for lack of a better term product out
there Forbes Magazine
who is an agent of the devil had a tweet
and they tweeted this nine times you
know now that elon's here Twitter's
child poor nightmare has gotten much
worse they tweet us nine times I looked
up anyone listeners can look up look at
Forbes and do a search they never
mentioned this problem before so now
that Elon is doing something about it
now it's a problem for you no it's a
problem elon's the problem it's not the
child porn that you guys had a problem
with and that to me is like yeah I
understand that you think that Elon is a
bad guy because he's upset your apple
cart this isn't a political issue this
isn't a gotcha moment this is all right
here are some tips we talked to 10
experts digital experts and here are
some techniques Mr musk that you might
want to take from us free of charge that
will help you solve this that would be a
great article
and I just want to use this opportunity
to say quite clearly and strongly that
even though Twitter and other parts of
the internet I are interpreting some of
my statements to me and I'm right
in this case meaning leaning right right
wing and in other cases leaning left
left wing I'm not I'm a political or at
least I try to be in my thinking take
one issue at a time I do take an opinion
on each issue at a time but I hate camps
I try to avoid political accounts in
general it just it sucks that
promoting transparency in this case or
celebrating transparency
um is somehow
connected to being right wing no it's
being made into so supposed euphemism
for being right wing
it's just it sucks uh it sucks even
though I'm wearing a red suit and this
is a very red themed conversation well
that's I mean the Revolution was the
color of blood